welcome everyone to what's new in
bigquery session
I'm Sudhir has day I'm the director of
product for smart analytics platform at
Google cloud and I'm Tina thrush go on a
product manager on Google bigquery at
Google cloud in the smart analytics team
our vision is to give you or provide you
with an enterprise class potatoe
platform with proven dependability and
Google we believe in building these
large-scale services that can meet all
your security and Trust needs so so we
basically have been focused on that in
addition to that we are also about being
open and flexible providing you with
choice and finally and most important we
want to embed intelligence across the
whole platform so that's our primary
vision in the smart analytics team let's
Rumble bigquery first Google bigquery
it's now 10 years old in June we
celebrated the 10th anniversary of
bigquery query has customers from a you
know few terabytes to hundreds of
petabytes it's a completely serverless
technology what do I mean by that
oh it means you don't have to worry
about any infrastructure pieces just
bring your data and start analyzing it
start writing queries on it
there's no monitoring there is no
administration there is no machines
there is no nodes there are no servers
that you need to worry about so most of
that is managed by by Google we take
care of all of that for you
the second thing we are highly
differentiated we provide you the
ability to ingest tens of millions of
events in real time into bigquery and
lot of organizations like our like King
which is a gaming company they have
in-game events that happen and they want
to stream that in real time so they can
analyze what what users are doing on
their platform so it's possible and menu
ingest large scale events it does not
impact your query performance on top of
top of the data because we completely
distribute or decouple of compute and
storage layer
in addition to that we have embedded
machine learning capability where you
can write sequel commands to create
machine learning models and get get
advanced predictions and finally we
don't want insights to be limited to few
in the organization we want insights for
every one of you made a lot of
investment in the space where bigquery
is being used by organizations like
AirAsia but they were able to reduce
their operational cost airline by five
to ten percent by making those insights
available to everybody in front lines
that they can make better decisions so
so those are those are the key
capabilities that we provide one thing
that bigquery is great at is scale we
are really powering some of the largest
of the workloads in analytic space our
largest customer has more than 350
petabytes of data in the data warehouse
one of the largest queries that was run
was roughly 100 trillion rows that were
queried in a single query and we have
seen up to 10,000 concurrent users being
you like no use by our customers so so
concurrency at a very high scale is also
supported let's talk about HSBC it's a
it's a systemic bank it's highly
regulated it just BC uses bigquery to
run large-scale analytics or lot of
regulatory reporting and all one of the
key things that we were able to do by
working with HSBC is provide a lot of
security capabilities in bigquery like
CMAC the festival manager encryption
keys virtual private connect so all of
these VP CSC all these capabilities we
built with with HSBC they are proven
they're they're used by some of the
largest banks in the world in HSBC's
case they bring data from 40-plus
countries all transaction data they put
it into into their data link / data
warehouse will be query they analyze all
of this data and at the end of the day
they have to report to regulators about
the viability of the
all the data and all of this is running
in few minutes which used to tape like I
think 30 hours on on-premise systems and
stuff like that and you have to do this
every day so in 30 hours you cannot go
ahead and report every day so so on on
bigquery we can do it in a few minutes
and it's allowing them to scale scale
their business so the core is much more
than a data warehouse because we have so
much advanced capabilities but one
strength of bigquery is the fact that it
is a part of a tightly integrated broad
smart emmalin's platform that includes
services like data prog data fusion and
even looker and actually the vast
majority of the query customers are
using a number of these services
together with the query and sky UK is
one of them of course sky is a
broadcaster and they provide these
enhanced set-top boxes that communicate
that directly to pops up beautiful and
the query for real-time analysis what
that enables Scott to do is to really
understand the customer deeply they're
able to understand what customers are
doing what they're watching their
preferences they're able to tailor
customized content and advertisements on
so forth and they even can do research
on customers by doing a/b testing and if
you look at the growth of bigquery like
we've seen tremendous growth in last
last year or so we have customers across
every industry vertical across every
region in the world we have large
customers like Home Depot to ups in in
in United States we have HSBC we have
sky we have King we have know various
different customers Metro picado in amia
because of customers and JPAC region
like fast retailing group in seed bank
and go check and aeration also so we
have we have seen adoption across the
globe bye-bye
different customers different kinds of
use cases and and synonyms so for
today's roadmap session what we did was
if you've taken some of the key
highlights in the roadmap and we are
going to share them with you and we're
going to do this across the three value
pillars that we have being open and
flexible intelligent and and proven in
dependability let's start with proving
dependability HSBC and sky of course
multinational corporations they'll put
their trust into the query to drive
their business forward
so we really need to take care of our
customers in this area and so what we
think about it is we enhance
dependability in four areas availability
and uptime administration and control
performance and just quarry execution
and finally trust security and
governance today we're announcing the
fact that we are enhancing our SLA by an
additional nine so now there's four
nines availability that we guarantee
right we're doing this free of charge to
all of our customers there's no special
rates that you have to pay the reason
we're able to do is is because we have
service architecture it's very advanced
radically unique architecture that does
guarantee against downtime and specific
circumstances so there's four nines of
availability is really only about four
minutes of downtime per month or less
than an hour per day and you note that
it is actually industry-leading when it
comes to cloud data warehouses all other
plans that are warehouses only offer
three nines of availability and of
course we care about performance and our
customers care about performance so we
started running this query in the last
few years to demonstrate the power of
the court this is a query that is a
simple point lookup but it is a query on
an entire petabytes worth of that so in
2016 when we first ran this query we had
executed about six minutes and scan the
whole petabyte in 2018 a couple years
later we executed this query in just two
minutes and it actually scanned about
400 men of megabytes today if you run
the score in bigquery you will notice
that it takes about force
that's wrong and the best part of all is
that you didn't need to do anything
special you didn't need to pay anything
extra to start getting this better
performance we just upgraded your
service for you seamlessly without any
downtime and you just got better
performance in fact just in 2020 alone
from the beginning of the year with me
major improvements to all the typical
industry standard benchmarks this is a
TBC D s benchmark and we're looking at
an geo mean of performance so both for
want eternity and ability scales we
improve performance aimer from 20 to 30%
and again you just get this performance
as part of using the query you don't
have to do anything and it just happens
so we have a number of customers in all
kinds of areas and of course sports
leagues and sports teams are taken
advantage of recorded a major league
baseball being the newest one there's a
breakdown da 204 that talks about the
journey that MLB took to kind of read
platform onto the court well the first
thing they notice when they start using
bigquery is the fact that they're able
to give this information to give
analytics to all the key stakeholders
when they made you look baseball and the
teams that are part of the league and
they're able to do some real-time right
they don't have these bottlenecks
anymore at the same time they're getting
performance that's significantly better
than the previous the previous platform
and finally it's very very easy for them
to manage this right because the queries
serverless there's really not a lot of
things for them to worry about and they
really like that
so we talked about how bigquery
serverless it doesn't require
administration that said the more
customers we have that are multinational
that are complicated they have lots of
business units the more they're asking
for better control better predictability
better visibility right so we've made
significant investments here just in
2020 alone we've launched a number of
improvements to the query the first one
being reservations reservations is an
enterprise-grade workload management
platform that allows you to achieve
predictable pricing
to make sure that all your workloads are
executing under the proper oscillates
and it's super efficient because it's
using auto capacity the next enhancement
is flex loss flex slots allow you to
purchase capacity just for a few seconds
at a time and you can cancel them
anytime you essentially get instant
capacity to make your workload demands
and for the classic database
administrators out there we've made a
number of enhancements as well one is
information schema these are just tables
that contain matter that are relevant to
your service we've made him handsome for
data types and we've made improvements
to sequel that as well I'm really
delighted about this feature it's coming
in the next few months the query slot
auto-scaling
so this kind of combines the best of
both worlds right you're getting the
price predictability of slots based
pricing and you get like the low
management overhead on this associate
with our on-demand model because slots
auto-scaling
allows you to configure your scaling
limits and your spend limits and
bigquery takes care of the rest we
simply scale up and down your workloads
depending on what you throw out the
court so some of the things that are
really relevant about this is the fact
that the supports to Auto powers and our
start mode so we can go from zero to
full scale and back to zero if you'd
like that because we are not powered by
the an so you get a lot of additional
advancement so for example we don't have
this pre warm period when you're not
getting optimal performance the second
you get your capacity performance is at
100% also if you have queries in flight
or is they're being executed
you can add capacity and those queries
would immediately start taking advantage
of that right so you can accelerate
queries in flight or using the quiz
slots Auto scale because we don't have
yes we're not powered by we're not
powered by local disk right so we don't
have those local disk bottlenecks if you
start running out of local disk you
start getting performance clips that are
unpredictable they're hard to monitor
for and hard to document we don't have
such problems right we always have hot
data for you and finally we kind of
already talked about the submit SLA
slides but we
can provide a high level of reliability
because we're immune to individual no
time no downtime in fact a huge portion
of the data center can come down and
you're not even going to notice that the
next feature we're launching
administration next two months is admin
panel you are now we have stock drive
Florida which is incredibly powerful but
our customers want us to also have the
query native monitoring capability so
admin panel will provide you with the
ability to monitor your queries your
slosh your resources your spent your
workloads in your users right in the
quarry from the query this will have a
real time component with so you can see
what's happening right the second and
you can go back in time several weeks
and months so how are you gonna use that
mint panel well you're going to be able
to figure out how your organization's
using the query in general who are your
top users what are the types of queries
don't run and you're also going to be
able to perform real-time root cause
analysis whenever things are wrong maybe
there's a for loop that went awry so you
want to catch that in your figure out
what's going on and move on
customers always ask us you have all
these price capabilities but how do I
choose which model to use which one is
the right one for me and you know how
much capacity show are purchased so
we're launching bigquery slot
recommender big choice lock recommender
we're going to run this intelligence and
we're going to send you inside
automatically that will actually
recommend whether you should be on the
on-demand model or whether you should
get on a slot mom and of course we're
going to do this too without sacrificing
your performance so we're gonna tell you
that there's a recommendation out there
it's going to recommend you to save
money without extra sacrificing
performance so we talked about
availability we talked about
administration we talked about
performance but probably the most
important aspect of the query is is
security right our customers trust us
with their data and their workloads and
we can't fail them so we have a kind of
a three prong strategy here the first
one is
the quarry is a part of Google and
Google employs thousands of the best
security engineers in the world there
they're working on security on custom
hardware networking penetration so on
and so forth and bigquery gets to
benefit from all of this innovation
that's the beauty of the quarry and
that's the first builder so you just get
a high level of security automatically
when the quarry
the second pillar is the fact that we're
giving you a number of controls and
configurations and services that enable
you to customize how much security you
want in your environment things like
pseudo mention customer management
corruption keys virtual private
networking but the key to this component
is data catalog data catalog is a
metadata management and discovery
service that we launched recently so
imagine your data coming into Google
Cloud data catalog can automatically
index that data then the data passes
through data loss prevention API removes
and tokenize sspi information and
private and secure information and then
you can apply tags and policies to this
data and and grant access to the right
levels of data to the right users inside
of your organization so it's a super
flexible super powerful platform for
data management that allows you to
really control how how your dad is
exposed internally and externally and
the third pillar that's critical to our
success here is the fact that we're
working with all the relevant agencies
to achieve these artists and
certifications right so if you're
storing medical data inside of the query
you know you can trust us because we
have HIPAA certification if you're
storing financial data inside of the
query you know you can trust us because
we have PCI certification if you're
doing business in Germany or Singapore
we have proper credentials as well and
with FedRAMP we can do business with
government or with that now now we
talked about proven dependability let's
switch gears talk about the intelligence
one of our key capabilities in Google
cloud is of course our capabilities
around machine learning in AI and we
people talk more about how we have and
embedded machine learning capabilities
that we are providing with the query
we'll also talk about some real-time
analytics improvements that we have done
but before that let's talk about
democratizing insights one of our key
value pillars in Google flower is we
want insights for everyone we want to
make sure every individual person in an
organization can get access to the
insights that a moment
so in this realm the first thing that we
are doing is refreshed to bigquery UI
and all of our customers have been
asking for capabilities in in bigquery
UI like multi-tab editing we are adding
that so so it's now available for
everyone to use it's a really great
experience where you can write multiple
different queries compare them but more
importantly it not only write sequel for
for bigquery you can also write dataflow
sequel and create streaming pipelines
with observe and dataflow and
combination with bigquery so so it does
allow you that that integrated
experience it's a faster IDE
and one of the other features I like is
this autocomplete for for me so it can
recommend or suggest what are the table
or fields that I should be using and
stuff like that so a lot of innovation
and investment going in that space and
the second thing I'm super excited about
this feature which is connected sheets
connected sheets is literally think
about Google sheet in front of bigquery
you can have petabyte scale data sets in
bigquery you can use sheets to go ahead
and create pivot tables charts are
functions and custom calculations on top
of the sheet and then all of that
actually runs on half of Bitcoin so it's
it's best of both worlds the great
experience with great analytical engine
I personally use this everyday I have a
29 plus billion row table I analyze data
from that every day about a product
usage what's working what's not working
and also so really this makes data at
scale accessible to all analysts who can
use spreadsheets within your
organization so really powerful tooling
but with that we don't want to stop at
analysts and
and just a few folks in the organization
you want to extend insights to everyone
else in the organization with that we
are announcing availability of data Q&A
or data Q&A is natural language
interface or bigquery you literally go
ahead and ask a question get an answer
it's as simple as that
there is no setup required on top of
bigquery for leveraging it you just
enable an API and pick the table that we
want the good and asked questions on and
we just make it possible for you so you
can just start leveraging it we also
believe that no one interface is the
right interface for for technology like
this right I think now organizations
want to build custom workflows and
custom experiences on top of such
technology so we do have the whole API
available for for documentation where
organizations can literally build their
own experiences but from Google site we
will be integrating it in Google sheets
with connected sheets plus data Q&A now
you have a very powerful experience we
will be providing chat pod experience
you will be working with a dialog flow
and various other experiences that we
can provide or directly including
bigquery UI we'll have have a version of
this all of this is actually built on on
internal Google technology analyzer is a
great paper that you can read more about
it on but fundamentally this the same
technology that powers Coogler assistant
and various other services and products
that we internally use analyzer gives us
the ability to go ahead and do question
parsing intent identification entity
matching all of that comes because of
Google's investment in this space of of
natural language conversational
understanding and we're just leveraging
parts of that now we are on bigquery
side making sure that that works really
well with your custom data sets and and
it can make it easy to go ahead and get
started without doing that much of
preparation and setup on your data sets
let me switch gears talk about embedded
machine learning one of the key
values that we have in bigquery team is
we want to bring computation to data not
the other way round we don't like moving
data copying data that's not the best
way of running lots in analytics and so
in the same realm 80% of time data
scientists we are spending in data
preparation according to some studies
now we want to avoid that with with
bigquery what you can do is just use two
lines of sequel to create machine
learning models you literally say create
model model name of time X regression
matrix factorization whatever you want
and then give the input dataset and we
will do everything for you on that we do
internal hyper parameter tuning bkb take
care of the whole whole system on the
back when we launched couple of years
back we only had regression and
logistical and linear regression models
from there we have come far far ahead we
now support of k-means clustering matrix
factorization in the I've seen lot of
organizations use this in combination
they do customer segmentation use in
k-means clustering they do matrix
factorization to find products that we
should recommend to those segments and
they basically done email campaigns and
ad campaigns on it so very common
pattern you can you can use use this or
in addition we've also launched time
series forecasting this is great for
inventory optimizations and stuff like
that so we see a lot of interest in in
this model but in addition to that we
have enabled bigquery ml to be the
sequel interface for a lot of our
capabilities in Floria so DN n
classifiers energy boost and auto ml
tables all are using cloudy I platform
services in behind the scenes and and
you still get the same consistent
experience that you have but most
importantly lot of our customers said to
us hey all these models
creating them easily and running batch
workloads great but I would love to use
these models in real time predictions
how do we enable that and so we enable
you to go ahead and export these models
directly into tensor flow model and so
you can export it a sense of remodel
then hosted in any of the serving
platform that supports transit which
will be a mail engine queue flow there
are various platforms available with
that we recovered the democratizing
insights especially data Q&A and
connected sheets embedded machine
learning the third area of innovation
that we have spent significant amount of
time is in real-time analytics as I
already mentioned we have customers
putting in like tens of millions of
events per second if then bickering and
just this year we rewrote our whole
storage engine from like a batch first
more to streaming mode so it's a
streaming first storage system now and
you can scale to any of your needs tens
of millions of events per second is
without any any problem the more
important is none of your queries will
get any have any impact on performance
because of that ingestion rate so we can
do tens of millions of events and give
you the same query performance in the
real time and that's coming the second
thing is materialized views we know when
you have lot of these data changes
happening batch or in-stream you want to
materialize your data set and views so
that you can easily power the dashboards
and reports that you may have all of
this is automated and once you create a
materialized view as the underlying data
changes we persisted in the materialized
view for you what that means is you
don't have to worry about scheduling
these you don't want to have to not have
to worry about when was the last update
me into the base table but nothing like
that we will always keep it consistent
and most important is query will be
routing what that means is if you fire
the query to bigquery and you created a
materialized views later and you have
this historical query we will
automatically take that query our query
parsing engine will realize that you
have a new materialized view which can
make the query run faster and we would
automatically leverage that so that's
there it's available in beta for you to
use now a bi engine is another third
investment in always fast on this fresh
theme for us a bi engine we launched the
BI engine nasty
working within a studio so that we had
an integrated experience you want to
test the technology make sure it can
scale to global means and all of that so
I think that is there a provides your
sub second latency query capability it
automatically choose your queries as
they come in and all but more
importantly in this year we are going to
extend that capability of BI engine
which is our in-memory caching engine to
all the queries in between so when the
query comes in it will be able to
leverage bigquery even from a standard
bigquery interface in addition to that
on your JDBC ODBC driver still supported
and also all of our BI partners like
tableau Nucor theissens
Domo power bi all of them will be able
to leverage the BI engine capability
that we have you just pick what your
size of cache prism everything will
automatically work and then and also one
of the other things will support a star
schemas so that all your BI workers are
taken care of extending that if you
really think from a staff perspective
you as customers today now have a choice
you can decide whether you want low
latency or you're okay with relatively
higher latency and you can decide how
much you want to use on the very hard
data with caching with with bi engine or
you just want to create materialized
view which we will keep fresh all the
time or you want to just use partition
tables or just for the storage layer
directly so all of this is a choice that
you have but you write the query we will
automatically first try it
bi engine not their go-to but you
realize you've not there for a
partitioning and buffering if not go to
the core storage however the data is
stored so so that's the key thing that
we have been working on you will always
get the best performance and the best
price so you can even pick and choose
how what you care about with that we
covered intelligence and and proven
dependability let's switch gears and
talk about open and flexible this is
another big theme for us
we'll cover like bigquery everywhere
flexible pricing as well as data
platform interoperability in this let's
talk about bigquery bigquery everywhere
we are introducing bigquery Omni
what is the query on me as I earlier
said we have this theory vision in in
bigquery where we like to bring compute
to data and not for customers have data
not in GCP not with him have data in AWS
s3 and maybe other other customers have
in Asscher so with bigquery Omni
available for AWS
we will allow you to write queries and
execute and do analysis on top of the
data that's stored in s3
what does this mean we will literally
run our compute engine of computation
engine of bigquery in AWS closer to your
data and what that means is you don't
have to worry about paying for this
egress charges or anything so you may
have tens of to hundreds of petabytes of
data in s3 you can start writing queries
with the same interface in bigquery
it was the same sequel dialect that we
support as well as like you know and run
it on AWS so so you'll be able to do do
computation in that and and then get
access to the results there are there
are two or three different kinds of use
cases that are becoming really prevalent
in this a lot of our customers I do have
split mode lot of our customers use
bigquery and GCP as well as they have
data in SP and AWS this is going to
allow you have a single interface to
analyze data across counts and as I said
we will be bringing out the bigquery
Omni for for Azure in coming quarters so
so that will extend it to that platform
too so so that's that's one the second
use case that is becoming pretty
prevalent is I have been talking to
large customers who have tens to
hundreds of petabytes in in s3 they
don't use GCP today but they're
intrigued with our capability is like
the bigquery ml embedded machine
learning capability and they want to use
it and so in this case what we can do is
we can enable those organizations to do
data preparation summarizing the data
identifying the key data sets that are
there and then just move the data that
you have to run a machine learning on to
GCP
on in bigquery and then those machine
learning models do advanced analytics
with it so so so those are the different
kinds of you
cases fear we have seen in the early
adoption that we have seen we have
learning as we go and we would love for
you to the request access get access to
this technology and and go innovate with
you in the space with that let's talk
about pricing so we talked about how big
Cory has some of the largest use cases
in the world but what's interesting is
the query you probably also has some of
the smallest use cases in the world and
its really because we built our system
to be scale-invariant and we build the
right pricing options to support that
kind of great end of scenarios so no
matter where you are in terms of scale
capability and requirements we're going
to have the right pricing options for
you so we do have a perpetual free tier
where you get 10 gigabytes of storage
for free and a whole terabyte of
execution query execution query
processing for free no strings attached
and we have pay-as-you-go pressing which
is service pricing incredibly efficient
you don't have to think about anything
but as you kind of graduate and and
become bigger and bigger you start
caring about additional capacity you
start caring about price predictability
so we have flex slots there and early
season launched and then all the way out
of the largest use cases you really care
about efficiency you care about price
predictability and you're working on
these types of annual budgets we have
flat rate pricing for you so wherever
you are the queries gonna have the right
pricing options for you and of course
you're not just using bigquery typically
our customers are running spark or close
down a panda's data frame other types of
execution engines and at the same time
they keep their data in other places are
Linda query storage right so whether
it's my sequel Postgres cloud sequel it
could be a potentially a big table it
could be Google Drive and it could be
open data lakes that Park and org so we
provide interoperability with all of
these layers so bigquery storage API and
its ecosystem of open source connectors
allow you to run spark pandas MapReduce
and other open source workloads
directly on top of the query storage at
high levels of through
and parallelism so it's as if you
running these workloads directly on open
storage directly on HDFS without
sacrificing performance it's very unique
differentiated capability of recording
now if you want to leverage bigquery
sequel and is but your data lives
outside of the query we provide that
capability right so cloud sequel
Federation allows you to in real time
access data in your relational databases
from the query execution engine using
you're familiar with equity sequel and
of course we support a part a and org
Federation which means that you can run
bigquery right on top of your data links
and finally your data may be living in
these other service providers like
stripe Marketo maybe have Google
internal data sets to live within
Adwords within YouTube and so on and so
forth
how do you get that data into data
warehouse you can enrich it and you can
join against your other relevant
business data we provide we provide
hundreds of connectors that are very
very easy to configure very easy to set
up and we take care of the rest
like once your connection is set up we
simply move that data into bigquery on
your behalf and now you can do it
advanced analytics on it and and this is
just a subset or summary of all the
different different capabilities that
we're announcing you know there's not
enough time in 30 minutes or 35 minutes
for us to cover everything there is a
lot of other sessions there are 30-plus
sessions that are happening so that you
should be able to get deep dives into
all of these different topics as well as
hear more about different aspects of the
of the roadmap I do want to highlight
one of the ESG studies bigquery is
providing the lowest total cost of
ownership for our customers across the
globe
I highly recommend looking at the study
and then try and get query out and then
finally we are the leaders in in all the
different magic quadrants from Gartner
as well as Forrester waves over last
couple of years this one example but one
of the things that I want to close today
by telling you is when Cove in 19 hit I
know the whole globe
everybody's is s fighting the the new
pandemic a lot of organizations came to
us they wanted to get access to data and
we were able to go ahead and make
20-plus datasets available globally
accessible shareable in bigquery we were
able to go ahead and make all the
computation on top of that free until I
think later part of the year the key
thing is bigquery does provide us this
platform that we can share data share
insights with the globe not just within
organizations and then that's really
really a great great feeling from from
the team's perspective are we want to
thank you today for joining us and
hearing what's new and bigquery thank
you